Rhonda santis he's making enemies
he's making enemies over there at The
View
Whoopi Goldberg is furious specifically
at Ron DeSantis she calls him a freak
who's trying to rewrite history
there is not America's history without
these brown and black people that's what
I want to hear him say tonight because
one of the things that he knows is he
knows that that women in particular have
worked and particularly Brown women have
worked their butts off to make sure that
he became the president and I need to
hear him say this bonehead
in Florida and in Texas is out of step
with America yeah he's out of step with
who we are as a nation because there is
no Nation without us
and I need I need to hear him say that
as my president yes I need to know that
he's aware that there are freaks out
there who are trying to change history
and he's not going to stand for it
that's what I want from you Joe
at least for that last part
fact check true there are freaks out
there who are trying to change and
rewrite history
it's not the freaks that Whoopi's
talking about but there are freaks
trying to do that in fact the most
prominent example of this in recent
years was called the 1619 project it was
a project of the New York Times that the
New York Times put millions and millions
of dollars into promoting it's now made
its way into schools it was written by
Nicole
was it Nicole Hannah Jones I think is
her name Nicole Hannah Jones whose
Central thesis the whole thesis of the
project was that a motivating the the
motivating factor for the American
Revolution was to preserve slavery and
so the the true date of America's
founding is not 1620 when the pilgrims
arrive on Mayflower it's not
1776 when the revolution kicks off no
it's 1619 when the first slave ships
arrived on the East Coast
the central thesis was proven wrong it
was debunked it wasn't even just
debunked by those of us on the right it
was debunked by left-wing academic
historians who said that this woman who
was setting out to rewrite history was
just making it up it was so thoroughly
debunked that the New York Times quietly
had to rewrite the thesis because not
even the New York Times which lies all
the time could defend it
that's who is rewriting history
the rewriting of history that we are
getting constantly
from the left almost exclusively from
the left and so what Rhonda Santos is
saying is we don't want those freaks
rewriting history Whoopi Whoopi you
should be thrilled the freaks who are
trying to rewrite history they're being
kicked out of the classrooms that's good
you should thank Ron DeSantis if Whoopi
Goldberg had read any history ever in
her life which I am skeptical
I'm skeptical of that Prospect speaking
of the power of historical narrative
because this is what it's about when
when
when the people who dismiss the culture
wars they say oh who cares who cares
about some stupid story in the New York
Times that then goes into some high
school and then the kids learn it in
their class it doesn't who what what
does that matter
who cares the left cares that's why the
left is trying to rewrite history and
the left is trying to rewrite history
because if you control the past you
control the future
if you control the past
and you promote a history that is true
that is our country is basically a good
place and we have an obligation to love
our country be as patriotism is an
extension of filial piety and America is
an expression of Western civilization
and Western Civilization is a good thing
and it's actually the greatest
civilization ever in the world and it's
animated by a good and True Religion
called Christianity and it's created the
most beautiful works of art the greatest
achievements that we've ever seen From
Any Human Society ever if you if you
have that view that is going to affect
the way that you interact with your
country today right now in the present
and it's going to affect the country
that you were going to have into the
future if on the other hand you have a
bunch of freaks in Whoopi Goldberg's
terms go in and rewrite history and say
actually America is the most evil place
ever and actually Western Civilization
they never did anything good they only
did bad stuff they're just colonizers
and imperialists and all the good good
stuff they ever got they just stole it
anyway and it's all built on slave labor
in the west actually the West is
responsible for slavery even though the
West has practiced slavery less than any
other civilization ever in the world and
today is the only part of the world that
has actually abolished slavery yet no
the West is responsible for that's why
it's so evil and oppressive and terrible
well that's going to affect the way you
you interact with your society today
and it's going to determine the sort of
society that you're gonna have in the
future because you're going to hate the
society that you've currently got and
you don't want to tear down the best
stuff about it that's that's why people
fight over history that's why the
conservatives need to stand firm that's
why Rhonda santis going in and and Glenn
young can going in and other people who
are fighting this academic battle right
now
that's why it matters when they go in
and they say no we're not going to teach
our students this crap because
classrooms are like crystal balls and
when you look into a classroom you were
seeing your country 20 years into the
future seven or eight years ago
conservatives love to say oh these
snowflakes on the college campuses these
woke snowflakes just wait till they get
to the real world that's going to be a
big surprise for them
no the woke people and the little
snowflakes
were smarter about this issue because
they knew that they were going to get
into the real world and they were just
going to change the world
and and change the way that we all had
to accommodate them they were going to
demand that we Bend our perceptions to
their absurd Wills
they want the classroom really was a
crystal ball
you see this playing out right now in
basic crime stories this is a really
really
disturbing a story I was reading it at
the daily wire
bicycling doctor allegedly murdered by
man who reportedly muttered about white
privilege California emergency room
doctor out for a ride on his mountain
bike was allegedly murdered Wednesday by
a man who police had struck him from
behind with his vehicle then jumped out
and repeatedly stabbed him while
according to a witness to crying white
privilege
this would be funny if it weren't so sad
but but think about the absurdity of
this
a guy is driving along I guess it was a
black guy who's driving along and
presumably wasn't a white guy although
these days I don't know the white
Liberals are so self-hating I guess it
could have been but but I assume it was
not a white guy he's driving along he
sees a white guy
he is enraged I imagine not merely by
the color of the guy's skin though I
suppose it could have been that but
maybe he's enraged by the bicyclist
riding too slowly maybe he's enraged by
the fact that this guy gets to go on a
bike ride while he's got to be driving
and he's he's working or something
whatever enraged him he gets out of he
hits the guy gets out of the car and
just starts stabbing this man to death
while claiming to be the victim himself
while claiming that the man that he is
murdering
is he's the oppressor
he's got all of the privilege
and he the murderer he is the oppressed
one
he's the one who doesn't have is he
stabbing this man since it's California
the guy's stabbing him will probably get
off of the warning
vehicle approach to cyclist at an
intersection
drove around the victim after hitting
him exited the vehicle went back and
just continued to assault the victim
because of white privilege
if you believe if you believe that if
you believe what you are taught in
schools and by the media and by the
government and everywhere in the pop
culture and by the diversity training at
your office and by everything in the
culture if you believe that white people
really are not only evil but the source
of all the evil in society the very
reason that Society is broken because
the the true evil that pervades our
country is whiteness structural
whiteness that we have to abolish then
because ideas have consequences you
might take it into your own hands to
abolish that whiteness by abolishing the
life of the white person that you run
into and you would feel totally
justified
if you are
not particularly intelligent as I can't
imagine this murderer is if you are not
particularly thoughtful or well educated
you could really believe that as you're
murdering someone you say wow I'm really
I'm doing the right thing
wow I stopped this guy from oppressing
me with his nice private bicycle ride
that's the consequence of critical race
Theory that's the consequence of the
critical studies departments in
universities and high schools now that
tell you that America is an evil country
and white people in particular are the
problem
and if you're not white you're justified
in doing whatever you want
to
victimize the alleged oppressors that's
the consequence of it
talk about freaks those are the freaks
[Music]